i hate intros my next life is the
villainous season one
episode one we kicked things off with
the main character katarina claus
as a kid who is kind of a pretentious
dick her father quickly introduces her
to another character in gerald stewart
she immediately develops a bit of a
crush on gerald and while walking around
with him she suddenly trips and hits her
head when this happens she remembers a
past life as a high school otaku
in her past life she was running late
for school ran into the street and was
killed at the age of 17.
when she wakes up and gathers her
bearings she realizes that she's now a
part of a noble family and also that
she's engaged to gerald
while reflecting on her new
circumstances she realizes that she's a
part of an atomic game that she was
playing before she died
not only that but she was reincarnated
as the antagonist of the story when she
thinks back in all the possible
scenarios in the game she realizes that
nothing really ends well for her
character the happiest ending she can
hope for is being exiled and the bad
ending is her getting killed by gerald
katarina devises a plan
and decides that the best course of
action is to get good at magic and
increase
her sword fighting skills so that she
can find a job even if she's exiled
excuse a short training montage showing
her getting stronger
later that night she is introduced to a
new sibling that she's going to be
living with in keith
inside of the game keith was a mistress
son so he gets picked on continuously by
his siblings
he's lonely or some [ __ ] so he turns
into a man [ __ ] the main character
makes him realize that he could go
monogamous so he does and if katarina
interferes with their relationship she
is exiled or killed goderita comes to
the conclusion that in order to prevent
this from happening she has to give
keith lots of attention that way he
doesn't turn into a man [ __ ] and then
fall in love with the heroine the two
start hanging out all the time the
katarina wants to see some of his magic
so he makes a giant dirt doll that
dances
katarina's kind of [ __ ] stupid so she
runs up and gets smacked in the face
knocking her unconscious yet again
turns out keith has really strong magic
but he has a hard time controlling it
which is why this happened this isn't
the first time this has happened because
keith had
also injured one of his brothers growing
up so he's extra hard on himself about
this one
katarina tries explaining that it's not
that big of a deal but he insists that
he can't be around her which is in turn
exactly like the game katarina isn't
having any of that [ __ ] so she breaks
down the door and tells him that she's
still not afraid of him and they
continue being friends
episode 2. while eating dinner
katarina's dad tells her that she's
received an invitation to a tea party
she's gonna have a slob with no manners
so they send keith along with her to
keep an eye on her when they arrive we
get an introduction of a new character
in mary hunt during the party katarina
slips off by herself and
ends up running into mary mary is really
good at taking their garden of flowers
they have
said katarina is struggling in her
farming endeavors to grow vegetables she
asks mary to come back to her place to
help her out with the help of mary she
is able to successfully grow some
vegetables and the two bond over the
course of that time and become friends
keith informs us that mary was often
verbally abused by her older sisters and
didn't feel like she had a place to
belong which is why she's so happy to
make a new friend he also tells her that
mary is engaged to prince allen who is
gerald's twin
brother alan apparently had a sheltered
upbringing that made him spoiled and
egotistical he feels a deep rivalry as
well as inferiority complex to his
brother gerald later on we get the
official introduction to prince allen
who isn't exactly too happy to see
katarina little [ __ ] demands that
katarina stop seducing mary things get a
little heated so alan challenges her to
a showdown he lets katarina decide and
since she doesn't have too many skills
she challenges him to a tree climbing
contest
he obviously loses but he keeps on
coming back every day to challenge her
again and again
after losing over and over one day he
shows up and gerald is there
they decided to change the competition
to a piano contest today even though
alan wins since gerald is there his
inferiority complex makes him put down
his skills katarina feels bad so she
catches up to him and explains that
nobody's perfect including his brother
because he's actually afraid of snakes
they kind of bond or whatever and this
makes alan feel a little bit better
episode 3 a couple days later katarina
gets an invitation to another tea party
hosted by gerald and alan well at the
tea party katarina wanders off by
herself and
ends up running into a dog
the dog winds up chasing her so she is
forced to hide in a tree
well in the tree she hears a group of
kids antagonizing another character
she jumps down from the tree and for
whatever reason this scares off kids
this is where she first meets the albino
sofia the two don't really talk much
because katarina runs off before she can
say anything
also attending the party is sophia's
brother nicole
katarina then runs into sofia at the
party she learns that both her and sofia
enjoy romance novels so she invites
sophia to her house to talk about it
when she comes over she also brings
along her brother
when she sees him she realizes that
nicole is another route in the game
interacting with him could cause a doom
flag but she decides that it's probably
okay to interact with sofia still they
too enjoy themselves sitting around and
talking about books
just before they leave katarina finds
out that sophia is a bit of a reject
because of the way she looks despite
that katarina still wants to be her
friend which means a lot to sofia sofia
mary and katarina all get together and
talk about books often then one day
while she was at sophia's house she
winds up talking to nicole they talk
about his family and he ends up smiling
which makes her a little hot and
bothered now we jump ahead seven years
to where katarina is 15. the whole gang
is all grown up and get together to
celebrate katarina's birthday
most of the party are all of the guys
sending subtle signals that they want to
[ __ ] her
episode 4. we see katarina and the
others heading off to the magic academy
where the story of the game takes place
after their first day we learned that
just like in the game gerald had come
across the main character
soon after we find out that keith had
encountered the main character also
the only difference is that in the game
keith had hit on the main character
whereas
now he had only met her because she had
dropped a handkerchief shortly after
while walking through the halls katarina
then comes face to face with the heroine
of the game
in maria the two don't say anything as
they pass each other but katarina knows
for sure that this is the heroine
after considering all of her options
again katarina decides that she needs to
become a farmer so that if she goes into
exile she'll have something to fall back
on instead of sword fighting and magic
with the school's permission she begins
growing a little crop
just like in the game katarina's friends
had joined the student council this
makes her go to the student council
office where she meets the student
council's president and serious dick
well there she ends up running into and
talking with maria maria is a bit of a
baker and katarina loves sweets so she
requests that maria make her some sweet
sometime and the two seem like they're
getting long later on katarina comes
across maria being bullied for being a
commoner
they knock maria's delicious pastries
onto the ground and this pisses katarina
off so she deters them from bullying her
yeah episode 5. it doesn't seem like any
of the characters from the game have
taken a serious interest in maria yet
that aside katarina hears that she's
still being bullied by nobles so she
asks keith to help find a way to protect
her they come to the complex conclusion
that they just need to stay with her and
if they do that that will deter the
bullying
again the same formula ensues katarina
comes across marie getting bullied and
she saves them the two girl closer
all that good stuff a couple days later
katarina decides that she wants to learn
more about farming so she drags keith
along to some fields to learn how they
grew them
after the two of them are finished they
decide that since they're near maria's
hometown they should go visit her
on her day off they find out in the
local village where her parents live so
they start heading to maria's house
they get caught by two girls saying that
maria's real father is actually noble
and that her family has fallen apart
once they arrive at maria's house they
all talk with her and her mother
we then get some more backstory on maria
while maria was growing up everything
was relatively normal until she realized
she had light magic
because of this everybody in the village
started assuming that maria was an
illegitimate child of a noble
maria started practicing baking in an
attempt to make some new friends but
none of them gave a [ __ ] now her mother
is just happy that she has some friends
and that she took up baking again
episode 6. now we hop ahead to where
everybody is on summer vacation
keith is the first one to give off some
rapey vibes where he almost kisses
katarina while she's sleeping
gerald invites katarina out to a lake
most likely to seduce her but that all
of the side characters wind up joining
them a bunch of filler content ensues
and then everybody heads back once
they're back katarina goes out shopping
with sofia and nicole
sofia winds up giving them some alone
time because she's secretly rooting for
her brother to date katarina he tries
making a move on her but of course you
can't ruin the harem dynamics so she
doesn't notice
the rest of the episode consists of
similar events with each of the guys
insinuating that each of them is
interested in katarina and of course
she's oblivious
episode 7 we get a flashback of
katarina's best friend from her past
life the girl is named sasaki and she
had met katarina when katarina fell on
her from a tree the two became very
close
and always talked about the game she's
stuck in called fortune lover when she
dies her best friend's really sad and so
she wishes that when she dies she gets
to meet her in another life
turns out this flashback is actually a
dream that sofia is having now we jump
ahead to where the students have to
undergo
a practical exam they are tasked with
going into ancient ruins where a great
mage used to live
there are various booby traps inside the
ruins which test the student's magical
abilities
one of the traps ends up separating
katarina from the rest of her group
sophia any cool then use their win magic
to pick up on her voice and find out
where she is
while they're heading to her she was
getting kind of hungry so she picked up
a sharp stone and was cutting mushrooms
with it she's kind of [ __ ] stupid so
she almost slips and falls but sofia
gets there just in time to save her
someone then uses wind magic to protect
them from the fall
at first katarina thought it was sophia
but it turns out it was someone else
they then realized that the stone
katarina was using to collect mushrooms
is actually the stone they're looking
for so they wind up passing the test
episode 8. one day mary and katarina
decide that they need to go to the
library in order to study it wouldn't be
much of a harem story if they didn't
find a way to include all the other side
characters so everybody heads to the
library
all of them wind up getting sucked into
a magic book except for mary and maria
the magic book will only let them out if
one of them can attain their greatest
desire
of course all of them want to nail
katarina so they're put in a situation
where they're trying to seduce her
mary and maria are watching all of these
stories unfold
and none of them are actually attaining
their desire it seems like they're gonna
be stuck in there forever until it gets
to katarina's turn katarina's only
desire is to eat more sweets
she starts out by eating a gingerbread
house and then starts inhaling all of
the sweets around
her until she's so big that the book
can't contain her this sets
everybody free and they all go back to
normal episode 9.
we learned that katarina has passed all
of her classes and is advancing to the
next grade
ben katarina's made and starts to recap
all of the current standings with
everybody
long story short gerald is obviously in
love with katarina and is engaged to her
keith is in love with katarina and very
opposed to gerald merrincker allen is in
love with katarina shocking but doesn't
understand his own feelings well enough
to know that he's in love with her like
[ __ ] idiot now we get into the yuri
action where mary is actually in love
with katherine also
she even suggested to katarina that they
both call off their engagements to their
fiances and run off together but
katarina thought she was joking
then there's nicole rarely changes his
expressions what he does with katarina
and why is that everybody yes it's
because he's in love with her and as for
sophia she hates this [ __ ] she hopes
she dies no actually she's in love with
her too but not in a romantic sense so
it's all good she just wants her boy
nicole to get in there so she's
constantly dropping hints to katarina
and mary loves her so she cooks her lots
of sweets later on all the girls make
plans to have a pajama party
while there they all try to probe each
other for who they wanna [ __ ] well
that's going on we start to get a little
bit more backstory on her maid anne
she was born to a cold-hearted prick
named baron shelley and one of his mates
tragedy struck when she was 15 because
her mother was killed in a house fire
she then found out that she was being
kept around by baron as a tool
so that she could be married into
another family during the fire her arm
was badly burned and baron sees this as
damaged goods so he has no use for her
and kicks her out of the house
this is when she was forced to become a
maid for the arrogant and selfish
katarina
after katarina had bumped her head her
personality of course changed and she
finally made anne feel like she had a
place that she belonged katarina even
stood up to baron when he came around
looking to force anne into a political
marriage
this gives ant the confidence to finally
stand up to the prick and tell him that
she's not getting married she feels like
katarina is the one responsible for
making her who she is
and because of that she vows to follow
her no matter what the next day it's
finally harvest day for katarina's crops
so everybody comes out to help her
episode 10. we come in on the group of
girls that were bullying maria
they're in the middle of accusing
katarina for doing a bunch of evil deeds
this is following the exact plotline of
the game when you get a doom flag
when the side characters get there
they're handed documents proving that
katarina has been doing evil things
in the game this is when all the
characters turn on katarina and she is
either killed or exiled
the difference is that when all the side
characters read everything they just get
confused and say that katarina's too
stupid to plan any of this
it seems that the bully's plans are
foiled so they run off while they're
running off maria notices some sort of
black miasma radiating from the girls
later on while walking maria again
notices this black miasma so she wants
to go investigate by herself why bring a
friend right well this back
fires and the [ __ ] goes missing
everybody goes out looking for her but
nobody can find her
after three days of her being gone
gerald finally gains some new
information
it seems the girls that were making the
accusations against katarina couldn't
remember why they did it they don't even
remember
where they got the documents with the
accusations on them this makes gerald
believe that somebody with dark magic
might be interfering
katarina had never heard of dark magic
only light magic which maria had
dark magic is a well-kept secret and
only a few people actually know about
its existence
it allows one to manipulate someone
else's heart amplifying negative
emotions like
envy and hatred once the people have
been affected by the dark magic they
also can't remember how it happened
on top of that dark magic can't be
detected by anybody except for people
who can use light magic
this is why maria was the only one who
could see the miasma radiating from the
girls
and the last little side note about dark
magic is that nobody is born with it it
has to be gained by sacrificing a human
life later on while sitting in the
courtyard katarina is approached by
sirius dick while talking with him she
suddenly remembers her friend from her
past
life talking about how there was a
hidden character this character is a
dark magic user a ginger and has gray
eyes just like
siri's dick in the game if you fail to
win him over he actually kills all of
the side characters in the worst ending
possible
she inadvertently asked him if he could
use dark magic at first he plays
innocent but then he ends up coming
clean saying that he was the one
responsible for abducting maria
she came around asking why there was
miasma radiating from him so he tries to
erase her memory when that fails he uses
some fumes on her to knock her
unconscious and take her away
he makes it clear that his target is
really katarina the only reason inky
gives is that he hates her because she
befriended all these lonely guys and
that makes her a hypocrite
all that being said katarina feels like
he's in pain and agony and kind of feels
bad for him
in the last couple of scenes she tries
to make him feel better but then he uses
his black magic honor
episode 11. we get some zero vibes when
katarina wakes up in her old life
everything seems like it's normal except
for the fact that she feels like she's
forgetting something
back in the other world katarina has
been asleep for two whole days and the
doctors don't know why
we then get a series of pointless
flashbacks from all the side characters
explaining how she influenced their
lives
in a cliche fashion they all unanimously
decide at the exact same moment that
they need to be by her side and send her
their positive energy
now we hop back on over to katarina who
goes to speak with sasaki after school
sasaki explains that this isn't her
world anymore and that people are
waiting for her katarina then begins to
hear the voices of everybody in the
other world calling out to her to wake
up
she then remembers the other world and
decides that even though she feels
comfortable in this world she needs to
get back to the people she loves
the world starts falling apart as
katarina prepares to make her departure
for whatever [ __ ] reason sasaki knows
the location of maria so she tells her
that she's in a hidden room in the
storehouse
just before katarina is gone sasaki
promises to stay by her side as sophia
this confirms that sophia is indeed the
reincarnate of sasaki once katarina
wakes up everybody gets all emotional or
whatever and then they all head out to
confront sirius and get maria back
they quickly find maria set her free and
then they proceed to confront sirius in
the last couple of scenes
episode 12. once everybody gets to
sirius we get a flashback of him as a
kid
his real name isn't actually serious
dick it's raphael
walt he was born because his mother was
a maid and had an affair with a marquee
the marquis wife had found out about the
affair and so she targeted his mother
the marquis and his wife had also had a
son named sirius dick but he was sickly
and was going to die
the wife decided that she was going to
transfer sirius soul
into raphael's body this would
ultimately save her son's life as well
as get back at raphael's mother she
prevents a man from getting to his
family in order to force him to perform
the ritual for her
because he has no choice he sacrifices
raphael's mother by stabbing her to
death and then makes the transfer using
that energy
once the transfer is complete the man
who performed the ritual is also stabbed
and killed by her underlings what the
wife didn't understand is that the
transfer was only for information
raphael had received all of sirius's
memories but he was still himself he
took on the identity of sirius dick to
plot his revenge against the wife
raphael calls katarina a hypocrite
saying that she can save all of these
other lonely guys but he's different and
she
can't save him she agrees that she can't
save him but instead she promises that
she'll still stay by his side and give
him somebody to talk to
this makes him think back on his mom and
how she loved him and wanted him to have
a good life
upon remembering this he decides to give
up on his plans of revenge and become
friends with everybody again
then there's a surge of power because
the man that was killed after he had
performed the ritual
actually started residing inside of
raphael's body
he was the one egging raphael on so that
he could get revenge on the wife for
killing him
raphael is able to free himself and the
dark magic dissipates
after that raphael goes to the
authorities and has the wife and her
underlings arrested for what they did
we then hop on over to the second year's
graduation party
katarina is curious to see who maria
finally fell in love with to no one's
surprise she says katarina and all the
psy characters share this sentiment as
well
later on we see that raphael had made
his return and he's gonna be working for
the department of magic which is still
on campus so they'll see him around
the game script has now ended so
katarina doesn't know what's ahead for
them
i'm gonna be doing the future seasons
and you can find that on the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the my next life has a
villainous recaps in the playlist on the
right side you can also find the links
in the description
below and the only thing i hate more
than intros is outros